hey guys Pete peppers here with walked
through for candy crush jelly level 123
a lot of people have been asking about
this and so I'm gonna make a video I'm
starting out making trying to make as
many specials as I can because I wanted
to stun her three times in a row I kind
of got myself in a situation here
obviously I don't want to I wanted to
get the stun so that I could blow up the
blockers but I don't want to let her
make this color bomb combo so I'm gonna
have to make a match over here somewhere
or at the bottom of the board with my
explosion and that'll get that out of
her green jelly in the beginning you
know the options are limited
it's hard to get to our jelly and so I I
don't have a problem making matches on
her side there I have to had to pass up
on the double color bomb because that
would have spread green all over the
place and so I just used the color bomb
to take out a color that wasn't on her
jelly so looking things over there's not
a lot going on here I'll go ahead and
hit my blockers still not much I can
make this red match and hit the blockers
again not a real big deal that it's
spread her jelly over unless it gets out
of hand this is kind of a decision here
the can make the color bomb but I think
it's probably a better idea to make a
couple other specials instead and then I
can make this fish on the red that'll
spread that out for me I can fire that
off it doesn't really matter you can't
really spread her jelly on an area that
it already exists so you know what I'm
you know basically what I'm trying to do
is you know just open things up now that
all the blockers are gone on her side
which is important too
and I have my stun move here so I can
actually make it I'll go ahead and knock
that blocker out to you but now I can
just make any match that you know that's
touching my jelly and it will actually
spread it wider and so you know that it
works right there and pretty good result
set up a couple things but this is kind
of the point and why this levels
frustrating is even though you know you
can get a lot of the board colored a
cover it doesn't really it's not really
that helpful unless you get all of her
jelly covered because it's going to go
back and forth pretty regularly so I'm
just going to keep making specials and
what I would like to do is I'd like to
make a combo but you know here like say
you know I made another fish I could
have made the other match but that'll
give me another turn to and you know I
got a pretty good cascade there so I
think here probably the fish and the
striped is the best because even though
it's not a special it'll spread that out
for me yeah so here we have a pretty
good amount of the board covered but
that's not really the end of the story
we're going to still look for specials
and still look for that combo I really
want to make this color bomb to the left
where I have the piece but I don't see
any way I can really drop anything down
there
so I'm gonna just I think I sort of I
don't like the block about that much on
this particular level but I think I'm
gonna make this red match because if I
don't then she's just gonna make it with
the green so kind of have to block there
I think here we can make the match on on
the jelly with the striped and it'll go
down and that gives us a pretty good
advantage unfortunately I left the fish
there
for her boo that's okay too and so we're
just scan the board see if we can't find
something in the neighborhood of a setup
move obviously when you play the Queen
it's tough too because you know most of
the things if you set it up she'll take
it if given the chance so here we'll
make another stripe and we got to fish I
think I think the two fish together is
actually a better match here I mean we
could match the red first and then but
yeah no I think I'll just if I match the
two fish that there she has four squares
so that'll take away three of them you
know of course with a couple back but
with five moves left you know we're just
trying to cover her squares more than
the like at the bottom of the board
where we have that going on I'm pretty
sure that if we cover her last one then
it'll give us the rest for free so let's
see I'll see if that works out all right
so definitely make the cut of a raft
candy and then I think yeah we'll set
this up for the next time there's really
no way that I mean it's possible that it
could we could get screwed over but I
don't think it's going to happen so now
if we make this combo with our last and
flee the fish will hit the one that yeah
it did and then we need a little bit of
help here but it worked out so you know
it's a tough level I had to play it
several times where I got finally got it
all to fall together but I think some of
the you know some of the tips to think
about here are don't worry about don't
try to you know manually just spread
your jam
without you know trying to set up
specials and combos and definitely use
the stun especially the three stun where
you get that spread you know you get
that little extra explosion that's going
to help a lot and don't be afraid to do
stuff on her side of the board
especially in the beginning because
unless she actually gets ours covered up
completely then it doesn't matter if
half the board or more is is it's
covered with her color its you know once
it is covered especially you know making
specials over there isn't that bad of a
deal if it's gonna set up things in the
future or you know it'll get rid of her
blockers and you know if we get the if
we stunner three times I'm making them
on her side it's it's still usually a
net positive like you know usually will
be to our advantage to do it so you know
hang in there it's a tough one I hope
this will help but you know a lot of
people have been asking about this hope
you guys will like the video if you find
it helpful and subscribe to my channel
because I try to make the best videos
with commentary whenever the levels are
really hard and I could use your support
so thanks a lot good luck see you later